You're saying our daughter from the future, yep kind of stuck here now anybody know what to do
I made a big mistake
This man is hiding in the shadows
You guys beat him at least see we're supposed to only because the time I changed
I know in the future what happens to me?
So anybody know what to do
This is so weird god, I love this place. I can't believe that's our daughter up there. No, I shouldn't be here
She could marty mcfly herself out of existence
She needs to be with her parents 30 years from now not us now the flash all-new episodes Tuesdays
Overnight on the CW. Hey everybody its charlie
We got a whole bunch of new flash footage and they finally revealed exactly what happened because of Norris mistake
So now we have a clear picture for what she changed
So we got to break it down. If you're brand new to the channel. Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
There's a new flash ring giveaway
I've also got details about when we're gonna get episode 1 of
titans and new trailers that are gonna be dropping at New York Comic Con
So I'll explain that at the end of the video
So the big thing here is that they confirmed Nora changed the pass multiple times causing the timeline to shift in cicadas favor
whereas
previously
he was either a
Villain of the week or he was one of the more minor villains they rolled right past him on their way to this crisis on
Infinite Earths moment in the future newspaper. We see them in the Time Vault
Nora has a mobile version of Gideon that glows
Purple that looks a little bit like the ones that the reverse-flash
Had when he first came back to try and find out what time Barry was from during season 2 that was like season 2
episode 10 so she has like a mobile emitter that seems like it will eventually
Evolve into that version of Gideon because remember Barry is the person that creates Gideon
so I'm assuming that it's just evolved a little bit by the time it's gotten to Nora's time period the look on his face when
She gives him the flash ring - he's a little confused because he's kind of excited in the moment like oh wow
You know, you have a spare suit that I can wear and obviously it turns out to be the season 1 suit
But the funny thing too is as that also reminds Barry of reverse flashes costume ring
So just remember that all the stuff that the reverse-flash uses the costume ring the mobile Gideon
It's all derived from
stuff that he got from Barry's tech that's left over in his time period he makes it much more advanced, but it's all
original stuff that Barry used at one time dur
The future is just that our version of berry hasn't got to the point where he's created that stuff yet
Cisco's really the person that creates a lot of that tech because he's the engineer
So he helps come up with it that might have something to do with his arc this season
But we might not get into that too much in the first couple of episodes
So we'll just have to wait and see about that
But you get a little bit of voiceover dialog from the new version of Harrison wells who we've actually seen on set
I believe that everyone's calling this Sherlock Wells
I think that's what Tom Cavanagh said at Comic Con but he's got this vest on he's got that slightly different haircut
So I think that his storyline is gonna dub tale more with
Elongated bands because they said that this season he would be more of a detective
So like he was a private eye when we first met him during season four
He's gonna go back to doing that during season five. So he says cicada has been hiding in the shadows
Then you literally see cicada in the shadows of all these different
disaster sites one of them in the airplane that we see
Crashing earlier in the trailer that's gonna be that big action scene from the first episode with Wally
No idea if Wally's in episode two or if he leaves at the end of episode one
He's only supposed to be in three or four episodes this season
So he might be around for the first two or three episodes before he leaves you get a brief
Look at cicadas face without the mask on remember, it's Chris Klein from the American Pie series
So you're definitely familiar with them. If you don't immediately remember his face when you hear his name you get a much more
well
Lit version of that deleted scene from the season four finale
Where you see the lightning bolt dagger get charged with what looks like speed force dark matter that
Probably has something to do with the satellite save in the dark matter
Explosion that the thinker was trying to set off around the earth the whole idea behind her mistake
Is that yeah breaking the satellite apart is part of that. That might be what helps
Supercharge, cicadas powers with this dagger. But remember he would have been a villain no matter what so at some point
He would have gotten this dagger
So that might be what happened in this moment when Nora helped destroy this satellite is it just sped up the process?
of cicada getting more powerful
It is no coincidence that you see the remnants of his dead child or children
here
Around the dagger and then they cut to the picture of team flash that Nora's looking at from season one like his family is dead
And Berry's family is still alive. So just meant to remind you why it is. Cicada is doing what he's doing
He's motivated by his dead children
He hates all metas the evil metas because they cause whatever accident it was that led to his children dying
But also probably just hates bury in team flash in general for existing deleting to that sort of escalation
remember the particle accelerator explosion in season one is what created all these metas that then went on to cause all these
disasters that the flash had to stop so remember when blackout during season one wanted to kill Harrison wells who was still secretly
reverse-flash
because he caused the
explosion that led to the death of all the people that he cared about is the same kind of thing with cicada and then of
course Berry asked the question of all questions
The one that you're never supposed to ask
What happens to me in the future? Probably a reference to what happens with?
cicada in the media future because doors like what you guys were supposed to beat him and apparently he beats you guys now because of
What I changed and it's also a reference to the future newspaper flash vanishes in crisis. What happens to me?
Why do I disappear why have I been staring at this newspaper for the past five years?
The thing about that future newspaper is that it's the Central City
Citizen that's gonna start as irises blog this season like you see her staring at this photo of the wreckage and you - she kind
Of picks out cicadas standing in the background during that montage when they talk about him standing in the shadows
So she's gonna grow the blog into a dominant news organization in the city
So that by the time she writes this future newspaper article buried disappearing
She becomes like the Lois Lane or the Perry White of News in Central City
So this sort of what her arc is gonna be about in addition to all this family stuff that's going on with Nora coming back
from the future in the drama between them like finding out why it is that Nora isn't so hot on iris but loves Barry so
Much. I think the idea is is the berry is dead in the future
So Nora is just really excited to meet her hero
Who she hasn't really known that well growing up only heard stories about and then of course, there's all the killer frost stuff
There's not a lot of her in the trailer with the person that they just cast as her father who turns out
Might wind up being icicle from the comics, even though those two characters aren't related in the comics. They might be bringing them together
I've got a lot of questions too about Kaitlyn's dead brother from earth-2
Who's also named Charlie just like me, but he didn't exist on earth one
so who knows what flashpoint changed they might introduce the idea of a dead brother just because when we started talking about
Icicle people were like, wait a minute. Are they gonna do icicle jr
As Kaitlyn's little brother that died, but I haven't heard anything about that as far as I know
It's just gonna be Kaitlyn her mother who we've already met in previous seasons in her father who's gonna be new to the show
And what's happening is is New York Comic Con is the week before that
They're dropping a daredevil season 3 trailer Titans is gonna have its world premiere. There'll be another trailer for that
So on Wednesday the 3rd all drop my Titans
Non-spoilery episode 1 review and just let everybody know what I think of it in general
But they're not gonna have any original shows until October 12th that Friday is when Titans officially premieres
It'll be a Friday night show and I'll just do as many videos as people want I'll at least do character videos
But if everybody hates the series then I'm not gonna do weekly videos for it
But if people think it's pretty cool, then I'll make more so we'll just see how it goes with that
So flash Tuesday's Titans Fridays arrow on Mondays
So I'll just remind people about the schedule as we do more videos. I'll name a new giveaway winner when I post new DC
There's new Captain Marvel that's dropping later this morning. So that'll be my next video
Click here to learn all about Henry Cavill becoming geralt of the witcher series on Netflix
Which is crazy and click here for brand new Captain Marvel. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight